i had totally blocked out of my mind
that there was a they ask you technical
questions because
i think i was so [ __ ] bad at it right
yeah because i remember i
had a question uh and it was asking me
like they were asking me like how
turbines work i knew how they worked
yeah but you know when you're in a room
with like two really old men who've been
doing this for years and they ask it
like they're like
how do you [ __ ] tell me how you [ __ ]
describe how you [ __ ] what
it's like it's like i know how to [ __ ]
but when they look at me like that and
they're asking me that way i'm like uh
uh
uh so um yeah the blades uh take the
oxygen in and they mix it with
am i right is this right this is right
yeah [ __ ] you know i remember i just
butchered it yeah
but also did you ever do video
interviews but you did but there's no
one to talk to
what video interviews
so if you passed the test right uh the
math test
and personality right they would say
that you wouldn't get an interview
you got a video video interview where
all you could see is yourself
yeah oh no i never had that but that
sounds horrible i've never had that i
messed up like
three times three times right and it was
like so basically what it was is there
would be
uh it [ __ ] felt like a mario [ __ ]
party quick time event
it would be there would be a slide right
where you could see yourself and it
would cut to your question
and then it would be like five four and
then you have to answer it and then
it was terrifying like one of them was
like so stupid it was like
so you know it's going and it's like you
know okay and then it was like
who's your biggest engineering
inspiration and i'm like
[Laughter]
i don't [ __ ] know my engineering idol
i'm like i just did this for the degree
i don't think about this [ __ ] i'm trying
to play card like what do you mean
like and so i was like [ __ ] [ __ ] uh uh
uh uh i said like einstein or something
and i'm not
i'm like basic [ __ ]
i'm not kidding right i said einstein
right i finished that question and
that's the
the next [ __ ] thing this is two of
seven questions the next thing i just
[ __ ] all f4
i'm like i haven't got this einstein
i was the most famous engineer in the
world
you might have heard of him because i
was like there's no way i'm getting it
with an answer like that
but that's asking what's your favorite
meal white bread i love it
i love white bread potatoes
it's like i i literally alter the next
question
who [ __ ] needs the rest of the
questions have you guys ever had like
group interviews
no no i remember i i had one and
like so this was like the second company
that i applied to
and we had like a team team building
interview
right that sounds horrible already yeah
and so our first task
was we were grouped up with another
person and i will never forget this
person
even though he's a [ __ ] genius but
i'll get to that later but like
um but like so our uh
so they were work they were gonna look
it out like our team building so
the very first task right was very
simple so
we get paired with someone and we had to
like learn as much
information about them as we can you
know like names hobbies yada yada yada
and then we'd have to like present that
to the group right as
like i'm sure that you saw it as an
icebreaker and everything
but you know you know the worst way
testing out like communication skills
and listening skills
and all the basic [ __ ] team working
stuff you want to do so i get
i get paired up um with dan thank you
dan
so like so like we get paired up and
immediately he just goes hey
my name my name's dan so here's how you
want to do it like
i'll say whatever i want to say about
you and you just say it's right and
you say whatever you want to say about
me and i'll just say it's right
i mean you know so we don't have to
worry about this stupid icebreaker
i'm just like genius genius
he starts he starts talking and he's you
know he gets my name right but he just
[ __ ] makes up
everything else about me like absolutely
i like i like to play fifa
that's so smart my favorite like my
favorite film is like i can't remember
what you [ __ ] said back then
yeah and so then it gets to my turn and
i'm like hey this is
dan he loves fifa no
like uh yeah he's uh he's x years old
he's like he's like 23 years old and
he's like nah
22. i'm like no yo yo are you [ __ ]
doing this right now
genius are you [ __ ] do is he is he
really [ __ ] me over like this right
now
and i started i say yeah and uh he likes
to play call of duty no i don't like
playing call of duty
wow top 10 anime portraits i was just
like
you [ __ ] you are [ __ ] me over
even though it's [ __ ] genius because
i am your competition
i [ __ ] hate you right now but i can't
hate you because i should have thought
of this oh that's some
[ __ ] movie villains yeah
i couldn't place someone like that
that's too hard holy [ __ ]
this this man was playing [ __ ] 5d
chess in the middle of that [ __ ] hell
i i [ __ ] hope you got the job like
jesus christ
could you imagine if you didn't get the
job after all that he just [ __ ] you
over for no reason
[Music]
hey man doggy dog world i respect that
i learned i learned i learned a harsh
lesson that day and i will never forget
it there you go uni graduates
[ __ ] of your opponents but that does
seem like the kind of thing where it's
like that's too good to be true when
someone else brings it to you right yeah
yeah yeah son of a [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
dead
keep keep your enemies close yeah god
damn wow